new york governor andrew cuomo is
blaming europe
for the coronavirus even as evidence
mounts that china knew about the virus
covered it up destroyed the world
economy and killed lots of people
but american leftists keep defending the
chinese communist party
because no less than their whole
political program rides on it
then a new york times writer wants you
to pay for her raising her own children
a judge issues a major ruling on
transgenderism before the case even
begins
and slate magazine comes up with a new
term for monogamy
all that and more i'm michael knowles
and this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
cuomo is blaming europe for the
coronavirus that one's new i would like
to know
your favorite name for the wubonic
plague
i know there have been so many kung flu
the the woofloo the uh chop flewy
the now andrew cuomo has added one to
the list
from a different continent the european
virus so i want to know which one
which one you like the most uh there is
a reason
that they're doing this there is a
reason why they're trying to shift blame
and take it away from china and put it
on europe we'll get to that in one
second
first i've got to thank our friends over
at ring really i've got to thank all of
our sponsors because
these are very challenging economic
times and
we really appreciate the sponsors who
have stuck with us allow us to keep the
show on the air we would appreciate it
if you would help them out as well and
go
support them ring more than ever
these days is necessary it's hard to
keep a close eye on things
more deliveries mean more boxes left
unattended
and more opportunities for packages to
go missing
a lot can happen outside of our front
doors and we're not always free to check
on things
in person with ring you keep your home
safe no matter where you are maybe
you're like me and you're at the office
right now
maybe you're not you're in the bedroom
maybe you're somewhere else you've gone
out of town
you can always check in on your home it
gives you a lot of peace of mind
around the clock from video doorbells
and security cameras
to smart security lighting and alarm
systems ring has everything you need to
make sure
your family and your belongings are safe
secure anytime
anywhere i love these guys i rely on
them i
trust them and i give them out to my
friends because they have this added
benefit
of being super cool and make you feel
like you're living in the future and
they're not very expensive so you get to
if you give them out as a gift you look
like a really cool guy
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kit right now when you go to ring.com
knowles that includes the ring video
doorbell 3 and chime pro it's all you
need
to start building a ring of security for
your home today just go to ring.com
knowles ring.com knowles
a virus by any other name
is just as deadly but the left doesn't
know that
and the left playing these new word
games when it comes to the coronavirus
is showing us a lot not just about how
they use words not just about political
correctness
not just about how they view the west
versus the east
it shows us a key part of the
liberal international political agenda
it shows us how desperate they are
to defend china here is andrew cuomo
bestowing
the new name on the wu flu the european
virus
if you had said when we started this
yes we have more cases than anyone else
yes
we had this european virus attack us and
nobody expected it
but we're not only going to change our
trajectory
we're going to change the trajectory
more dramatically than any place
else in the nation so the first
issue of course with what he's saying is
it's not true the virus doesn't come
from europe
there's no evidence the virus comes from
europe no one before andrew cuomo has
ever even suggested that the virus
comes from europe that's the first part
of it the second part of it was his
delivery
delivery wasn't great he know he knew
what he was doing
he's trying to be provocative and change
the conversation say
oh you say it's from china well you know
what i say it's from europe
uh you know governor cuomo it actually
is from china we know that for a fact
yeah okay well uh maybe okay whatever i
say it's from europe
but he the way he delivered it was
halting it was awkward he
knows even he andrew cuomo a trained
liar for his whole life
knows that that isn't true the third
issue with this is
isn't that racist by the left standards
remember the left said
if you say where the virus comes from
then that's racist
and bigoted and terrible you can't call
it the chinese virus
or the chinese coronavirus that's wrong
but you can call it the european virus
of course that's the way that's the way
the left always works
if they didn't have double standards
they would have no standards
at all it's okay
to demean your own country and your own
civilization
you're i mean i guess europe's not our
country but it's the country or it's the
continent that we come from it's the
civilization
that we come from here in america so
you're allowed to demean that but you're
not allowed to demean foreign places
because according to the
left the west is bad and everywhere else
is good
according to the left our civilization
is bad everywhere else is good
and so we we deserve all the scoring
that we can get
but it isn't true and the the way that
cuomo defended this
argument is he said well we shut down
flights from china
but we didn't shut down flights from
europe even though we actually did but
it took a few weeks longer
and so people were coming in from europe
and maybe they had the virus and it
doesn't matter where it came from
in the first place not a very good
argument of course
but it's more than just political
correctness run amok it's more than just
a westerner hating his own civilization
china
actually matters to the left's ongoing
international agenda okay
so there's this fight that's coming down
the fight over who to blame for the
virus is not just about
pointing fingers for the heck of it it's
about where we go from here as a
civilization and obviously
on the on the don't blame china side
you've got andy cuomo making up new
phrases
on the blame china side you have more
and more evidence mounting
senator tom cotton was on maria
bartoromo's show the other day
and maria has been very good on sussing
out
what's really going on with this story
senator cotton
pointed out that it appears from cell
phone data
that there were road closures around
wuhan
way way back at the very beginning of
this virus
road closures suggesting that the
chinese government knew about this
they were trying to stop it in their own
country but they weren't blowing the
whistle
to help save the rest of us there is
cell phone data
that we have seen now that indicates
that there was
a shutdown of the wuhan virology lab
the origin likely origin of the
chronovirus
explain the cell phone data and why it's
important maria
reports emerged yesterday in the media
that publicly available cell phone data
suggests that roads around the
lab in wuhan was closed in the middle of
october
again this information is publicly
available american media has used it to
analyze
mobility patterns and states to see if
our people
are practicing social distancing so the
reports indicate
that on major roads around these labs
and wuhan you obviously had
thousands and thousands of cell phones
pinging towers day in and day out and
then all of a sudden in october it
stopped and it remained stopped for
several days
that would suggest without any further
information
that those roads were blocked for some
reason
i think these two guys andy cuomo and
tom cotton do a pretty good job of
representing the two sides in this
debate
over china's guilt in the coronavirus if
any cuomo he says
it's not china it's europe it's europe's
fault and then you have tom cotton he
said well actually we have the data from
the cell phones for weeks and weeks and
we can see the road closures very
precisely around this time
and then andy cuomo cut them off goes no
not china la la la i can't hear you
that's it the evidence is all on tom
cotton's side
forget just the wuhan cell phone data we
now have a report out of german
intelligence
that when china found out about the
virus which happened very early on
xi jinping the head of the chinese
communist party personally called
the head of the world health
organization tedros adanum
gabrizius and told him
to cover it up so
according to this new report from german
intelligence
the world could have gained four to six
weeks in tackling the coronavirus
if xi jinping had not personally asked
the who chief
to delay warning the rest of the world
about human to human transmission you
remember early on who was saying there's
no human to human transmission don't
worry calm down they weren't sending
anybody to china
we thought why why are you jumping on
this why are you trying to downplay this
now we think we have an answer we think
it's because xi jinping
was the one who pushed it don't forget
there was a
survey or study that came out of
university of southampton probably a
month
or a month and a half ago now which said
if the coronavirus
had not been covered up for just one
extra week if china had just acted one
week more quickly than they did
they could have reduced the spread of
this virus by 66 around the world
if they had acted two weeks earlier they
would have reduced it
by 86 if they had acted
three weeks earlier just three weeks
they could have reduced the spread by 95
percent
the global economy would not have shut
down many many people would still be
alive today
and they didn't do it and now we have
even more information that china covered
it up
because we got it out of german
intelligence that call that from xi
jinping to the who was reportedly on
january 21st that far
back so the evidence is totally clear
and yet
the mainstream media the main
mouthpieces for the left
continue to carry water for the chinese
communist party
this time we saw it just this week on 60
minutes we'll get to that in one second
first
i got to thank our friends over a rock
auto you know
how when you go to the auto parts store
they never actually have
what your car needs and then they end up
ordering it on the internet and they
probably actually go to rockauto.com
and then they charge you twice as much
you know that you know when that happens
well
skip that step that's what happens to me
you can skip it rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather
than changing prices all the time with a
bunch of gimmicks why spend up to twice
as much
for the same parts like for instance
let's say you need a delphi
fg 1456 fuel pump assembly for a 2005 to
2010 honda odyssey
and you don't even know what that part
looks like if you're like me and you
find out that it costs 354 dollars at
the big store
the big brick and mortar well you could
get that exact part on rock auto for 217
bucks
i wouldn't have known that if i had gone
into the store that's why i rely
on rock auto great guys family company
they've been serving people online
basically as long as the internet's been
around go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and then write knowles knwles
in the how did you hear about us box so
that they know that we
sent you so evidence clear right i mean
we could go on and on and on showing all
the evidence for china's
guilt but i think you get the point all
right there's no evidence on the other
side
that china is somehow not guilty for
this
cbs news doesn't want to hear it cbs
news on 60 minutes which is
very major television news program
highly respected been around for a long
time
60 minutes is doing its level best
to get china off the hook
and to actually place blame not just on
europe but even
on the united states so just listen to
the kind of language they use
to cover for china why did the president
just cancel dasak's funding
it's the kind of politics which might
seem ill-advised in a health crisis
president trump is blaming china's
government for the pandemic
the outbreak was first detected in the
city of wuhan
the administration has said at times the
virus is man-made or that if it's
natural
it must have leaked out of a chinese
government lab
both the white house and the chinese
communist party have been
less than honest and so in china
and in the u.s the work of scientists
like peter dasak
is being undercut by pandemic politics
so just stop it right there for a moment
you see what he does
he says so the big dishonesty here is
that the united states said that this
might have come from a lab
which by the way every single day it
seems more and more likely that this
virus came from the lab
as as not just senators but as other
scientists have been talking about
as well and he says but
look and maybe china hasn't been totally
honest but it's mostly the examples i'm
going to give you are how the united
states hasn't been honest
and so at the very least we can say both
sides haven't been honest it's this
false equivalency
between china which
created the virus one way or another
whether it was made in nature
and then observed in the wuhan
laboratory or whether it was made in
nature and
just happened to escape into the world
because of these wuhan wet markets
because of these unsafe
food practices which by the way does not
seem very likely
but even if it were that is china's
fault
and they're lying about it and then
the united states calls them out for it
but because it's not
100 certain that that's what happened
because we don't know because china
covered it up then you're saying the
united states
is also dishonest bizarre behavior
especially
for an allegedly american television
news program
then he tries to pull out and say look
there's really just this third party
called the scientists
and they're the ones that we need to
follow and both of the political actors
china and the united states they're
basically both the same
and so don't give the u.s any more
credit than you give to china
then he goes on to defend even more the
alleged objectivity
untouchability of the scientists the
wuhan institute is
internationally respected two years ago
a team from the u.s embassy visited
that team sent a cable to washington
concerned that
one lab in the complex had a serious
shortage of trained investigators
but the cable first reported by the
washington post
emphasized the wuhan institute is
critical to future
outbreak prediction and prevention so
what this guy just did is what i call
the compliment sandwich
it's what a lot of flatterers will do
too
and it's what a lot of pr people will do
if they want to break some bad news
they'll say a really
a good thing then they'll put the
criticism in there and then they'll say
another really good thing
so he opens up he says the wuhan
institute of virology is
internationally respected uh no i don't
think it is
i think actually it's the least
respected lab in the world right now i
think people hate the damn
institute of virology and wuhan because
it gave us this global plague
so no it's not internationally respected
also how do i know it's not
internationally respected
because the very next thing he says is
you know some uh
some u.s inspectors pointed out that it
wasn't very safe
but but but it was only one lab and it
wasn't all it wasn't all the places and
but yeah it wasn't very safe okay well
if it's not very safe then
how on earth would you call it
internationally respected and actually
the people who pointed out that wasn't
safe
were international in china and then
they say but it's very important this
this lab is very important in fighting
diseases
no it clearly isn't it would appear that
the lab is very important in spreading
diseases
so one good way to fight those diseases
might be
to shut down the lab and not fund it as
we in the united states did
and as a lot of people including dr
fauci seem to be
involved with this decision to fund the
laboratory
but that's the complement sandwich it's
really great lab yeah okay they might
have started this global pandemic
but it's a really great lab then
we get to the real
criticism of america so far we haven't
had any criticism of china just about
but then we get to the criticism of
america the victim of this crime
china is the perpetrator america is the
victim cbs blames the victim
i mean this we are now in a case where
you have a rapist
and a victim and cbs 6 60 minutes is
covering it
and they say well she was wearing an
awfully short skirt
well she shouldn't have been out in that
neighborhood at night i mean that that
is the kind of
victim blaming you hear that phrase from
the left a lot this is a perfect example
of that
victim blaming from the mainstream media
we'll get to that in one second first
though
i've got to thank our friends over at
with people holsters you know
if you have a good handgun but no
holster
then you are just not doing gun
ownership right
and especially now especially with the
people holsters you can get a holster
for an unbelievable price
be safe holster that new gun in a we the
people holster starting at just
39 39 to get a we the people holster
which is custom designed to fit your
firearm perfectly
made right here in the usa not in other
places
that maybe are not so good to us around
the world they have thousands of options
to choose from plus an amazing selection
of printed holsters
their proprietary clip design allows you
to easily adjust both the cant
and ride of your holster so it will fit
comfortably and securely at all times
and now is the time i don't even need to
say it
to support american companies you know
that
you know supporting a holster company
that is made in america
is i think basically the most patriotic
thing you can do so go to
wethepeopleholsters.com
knowles right now to get yours every
holster ships free
comes with a lifetime guarantee and wait
for this
you get an additional 10 bucks off with
the offer code
knowles k-n-w-l-e-s satisfaction
guaranteed if it's not a perfect fit
send it back for a total refund
we the peopleholsters.com knowles we the
peopleholsters.com
slash knowles offer code knowles you get
the 39
holster 10 bucks off so it's 29 plus
free shipping
go do it i'm practically giving these
away to you
you have the compliment sandwich then
cbs gets to the hard work of blaming
america
eco health's work with wuhan ended
one week after mr trump's briefing room
pledge
when the nih revoked the grant initially
president trump praised china but in the
following weeks
testing in the u.s failed to catch up to
the need
vital equipment was short bodies filled
refrigerated trailers
and science was continuously challenged
as the u.s
led the world in illness and death the
white house moved the focus to the
chinese government nothing
that he just said is true nothing not i
don't think one syllable of that was
true
initially he blames america for
defunding the wuhan laboratory as if
this is some great tragedy
you know what if you start a global
pandemic
if you're and i'm not saying they
constructed the virus right this is the
left-wing trick
they say there is no evidence that they
constructed the virus in the lab
nobody is saying they constructed the
virus we're simply saying that the virus
was very likely present in the lab and
may have escaped
and a lot of evidence is suggesting that
that was the case
they're saying they're trying to
obviously fight a straw man because they
can't argue against that
pretty salient observation he says
defunding the wuhan lab was a terrible
idea if starting a global pandemic
is not enough to get your lab defunded
then there is no
criterion for getting your lab defunded
of course we should have done that
then he says the bodies started piling
up in the united states
as the united states led the world in
death and carnage
no we didn't china did but china is
lying about their numbers you can follow
every other country on earth you look at
the progression of the virus it goes up
up up right and
maybe there's a little plateau but it
keeps following this pattern with china
it goes up up up and then one day it
just completely drops down
now do you think that's because the
chinese people
have some amazing fact of their biology
that all on one day
just shuts down viruses do you think
that the chinese have some amazing
magic some wizardry where they wave a
wand and then just one day magically the
virus goes away or
is the communist party lying about their
numbers
guess what it's the latter how do we
know that they actually admitted they
were lying about the numbers
they're still lying but they admitted
that the numbers out of wuhan were not
true
so that total total shill for the
the chinese communist party then he
keeps going on and says
science was being denied in the united
states science was being denied
who's denying science here the one who
believes
that the virus just magically
disappeared in china one day
the one who believes that the laboratory
that very likely started this pandemic
still should be funded the the who which
science is being denied which model
because all the models contradicted each
other and it turns out they were all
wrong too
who who is denying science he of course
is treating scientists though it's a
sort of
religious faith you could you could be a
denier but you know then you're a
heretic you ought to be burned at the
stake practically when in fact
science oh we could do a whole episode
on the word science the word science
just means knowledge
right that's it comes from shire the
latin word shire to know
and the the word has been so politicized
now that one one political interest
group the
these materialists people who engage in
a very modern study of empirical
material investigation
have now monopolized the entire word for
knowledge
that's a whole other issue but it does
play into the politics here because what
he is saying when he talks about
science being denied is we know
everything we know it we have we have a
monopoly on the facts we have a monopoly
on information
and it's being denied by mean old
conservatives like donald trump
and that is why the u.s has led the
world in death and destruction none of
which
is true and then he takes one final
swipe to defend china
that's where this began last sunday
secretary of state mike pompeo attempted
to resurrect a debunked theory
that the virus was man-made in china
there it is did i predict it i predicted
it it's a debunked theory that the virus
was man-made first of all that's not
debunked until you debunk
that theory we know very little about
this virus to begin with but second of
all
nobody's saying it was man-made we're
saying it had something to do with the
laboratory those are two
completely different things and because
the
ccp's lap dogs in the american media
can't actually argue against
what appears to be pretty likely that
the the lab had something to do with the
virus
they try to argue against this straw man
this is not just about orange man bad
it's that's part of it this is not just
about
trump doesn't like china so the left
does like china
the left has been pushing china for
years
you remember joe biden i think i forget
when this was maybe
five six years ago something like that
joe biden was giving a speech
on this topic actually with some
lucidity with some clarity those are
rare attributes for joe biden these days
but he was addressing the real question
real question at the time
and today was is a rising china
good for america obviously it's good for
china it's good for china to be able to
lift people out of poverty it's good for
china
to be able to i don't know have more
material goods it's good for them
but is it good for the rest of the world
that this brutal
vicious government the ccp is growing
in strength and influence and joe
biden's response
was emphatically yes there was a debate
here in the united states and quite
frankly throughout most of the west is
whether a rising
china was in the interest of the united
states and the wider world
as a young member of the foreign
relations committee i wrote and i said
and i believe then what i believe now
that a rising china is a positive
positive development
not only for china but for america and
the world writ large
can't get clearer than that i think
maybe joe is doing better for himself
these days that he just kind of mumbles
confusedly in these meandering stories
about corn pop
because when he says his actual views
about
politics they're not so great they're
not so popular they're not so smart
maybe that's why joe biden doesn't want
his files opened up at the university of
delaware he told us that he said i don't
want people to know my positions on
things
there are a lot of speeches and policy
positions i've had in there okay well
yeah you're right we probably don't want
to hear those things
because you were dead wrong about the
most important political questions
of our time the left has been pushing
this and for
for many years decades now at this point
that we need to have a rising
china donald trump comes in and says no
we don't
there was a kind of consensus on the
left and the right rising china is good
globalization is good
big markets all over the world that's a
good thing we're all just going to have
total unfettered free trade and there's
there aren't going to be any
distinctions
trump comes on the scene and says no
china's
not treating us right we need to have
our own
national policies regardless of what it
means
for china themselves and so he takes
this hard line
at uh at the white house briefing
yesterday
the the media kept pushing this idea
that the virus is like america's fault
or europe's fault
and president trump pushes back as
always he goes
ask china put your focus back on
china the real source of the problem
many times that
the u.s is doing far better than any
other country
when it comes to testing yes why does
that matter
why is this a global competition to you
if every day americans are still
losing their lives and we're still
seeing more cases
every day well they're losing their
lives everywhere in the world
and maybe that's a question you should
ask china
don't ask me ask chyna that question
okay when you ask them that question you
may get a very
unusual answer yes behind you please
sir why are you saying that to me
specifically i'm telling you
i'm not saying it specifically to
anybody i'm saying it to anybody that
would ask a nasty question
please go ahead why does it matter okay
uh
anybody else please go ahead in the back
please
place
no it's okay but you appointed to me i
have two questions mr next
next please you did you called on me i
did
and you didn't respond and now i'm
calling on sorry
young lady in the back please i just
wanted to let my colleagues ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much
appreciate it thank you very much i love
the way he handled this that that woman
that first woman that asked the question
should be fired i mean she won't be
fired because she she wasn't doing her
job as a reporter but she was doing her
job as a leftist hack
so obviously she'll probably get a
promotion she's going to be the editor
wherever she is
she asks the question she basically
makes the accusation that america
is doing a terrible job on the virus and
letting lots of people die
and is probably to blame for a lot of
the pandemic right a lot of a lot of
that we're not controlling the spread
and trump says what are you talking
about ask china they're the one that
actually is to blame for all of this
and she doesn't have an answer for that
because she knows it's true so she says
the woman if you couldn't see the clip
the woman is is asian
and so she says why'd you ask me that
question specifically
why'd you tell me to do that
specifically
is this the first time you've ever heard
trump say talk to china
i don't think so i think trump's been
saying that since he came down the
elevator in 2015.
i think he's been saying that almost as
much as build the wall these days a lot
more than build the wall
so it's a totally dishonest disingenuous
uh playing of the race card from this
woman
whatever reporter she is whatever she
works for she why'd you ask me it's
because you're a racist or something
like that
and then he says it was a nasty question
and she fights back she goes it's not a
nasty question
but why does it matter that gives away
the game why does it matter
when it comes to china you said it
matters who's to blame
you said it matters whose policies are
not working that well right
you said it matters when you blame the
united states but then all of a sudden
when you mention that it's actually
china's fault it doesn't matter
we're not allowed to use a term that
describes where the virus comes from
when we call it the wuhan virus
or the chop fluid or the bubonic plague
or whatever you're not allowed that's
terrible and bigoted and racist and
sexist probably and i don't know maybe
it's homophobic too i don't it's all
those
isms right but then when you call it the
european virus like andy cuomo that's a
fine thing
that's all well and good
this didn't stop in the white house
briefing later on on cnn you had
brian stelter there making the same
racism accusation
why all the fighting over china because
china is the key
to the current liberal agenda china is
the key
to globalization we'll get to that in a
second we'll get to the new york times
begging you to pay to raise their
children we will get to
the cost of life and we'll get to a
very troubling new development in the
legal battle over the definition of sex
and transgenderism
first though i've got to thank you
i got to thank you and i got to tell you
about daily wire's newest
most exclusive membership tier the all
access tier
you get so much what you get the tumbler
you know you need that you get the new
all-access show i call it a show but
it's not really a show
it's just kind of hanging out and you
turn the camera on and
ask questions i did an elvis impression
on it the other day there's a lot of
stuff
it's a lot of stuff in there head on
over to dailywire.com
subscribe join daily wires all access
club with a new membership or an upgrade
get 10 percent off with coupon code
knowles k wlas
that's dailywire.com subscribe see you
there
so the the woman in the in the press
briefing calls trump a racist
for mentioning china because it's the
last card they've got right it's the
last refuge of a scoundrel
and then brian stelter on cnn doubles
down
says this is key evident ignore the
question ignore the point
this is just evidence of trump's bigotry
well clearly the president was rattled
rattled enough to walk off because he
didn't want to hear the questions from
caitlin collins
and wijajang and i think what we saw in
that exchange of wieser zhang
is something that has racial overtones
it is racist to look at an
asian-american white house correspondent
and say
ask china this isn't happening in a
vacuum
this is part of a pattern of behavior
from the president that goes back many
years so he's
he doesn't have the benefit of the doubt
that someone might have if
for the first time ever in their life
they made a comment like that to a
reporter
but the president has been rattled by
ways of zhang's questions in the past
he has treated her and other female
reporters differently in the past
and he's also had this pattern of
reacting to minority journalists in a
very specific and different way wolf
listen to what he's saying he's saying
that if president trump mentions
china and the person he's talking to is
asian if anybody that he's talking to is
asian he mentions
china that's racist and he's not allowed
to do it
they can't get more obvious about it
what they're telling you is hey
when you are trying to upset our agenda
shut up hey okay look
you want to blame china we want to blame
anybody but china
so saying china is racist do you
remember they did this to trump
the last time he was at a press briefing
and an asian reporter
who said she was from hong kong came out
and
asked this very fluffy question for
china and he said who do you work for
she has phoenix tv
he goes yes that owned by the chinese
communist party she goes no no it's
owned by hong kong
yeah you sure and so then he answered
the question
the left went crazy they said he's a
racist he's calling out this asian
reporter and suggesting that she works
with the chinese communist government
guess what
she did the news organization phoenix tv
is owned by the chinese government they
actually
bought a station just over the border in
mexico and they're broadcasting into
southern california where i am right now
and senator senator cruz and i spoke
about this on our show verdict
and senator cruz is now trying to get
that uh
that tv station shut down uh but
trump was right the first time on this
they still called him racist and then
here
he's not making any sort of suggestion
or that you know this woman's working
for china
he's just saying ask china like he's
asked of many other reporters
throughout this entire crisis and they
play the race card
china is the key that's that's what this
is about okay it's not just about orange
man bad china is the key to
globalization
china is the key to the liberal world
order there's a reason that
that the left and parts of the right the
globalist
right or the kind of you know
economists and soffaster an accountant
right the the right that just looks at
the world as an economic question
they've been pushing china for so long
that
vision of the world is one in which
we'll have relative peace all around the
world as long as we keep expanding
markets
and the most important market to expand
to is china obviously
because they've got the most people and
they keep buying up all of our news
media
they keep buying up all of our sports
they keep buying up all of our hollywood
movies they're the key that's why
hollywood is really nice to them the
news media really nice to them and the
nba and you remember there was that nba
scandal
where there was some criticism made of
the chinese government by an nba
employee there was some support given to
hong kong and they had to back off of
that
they had to defend the chinese
communists over the pro-democracy
protesters in hong kong
because he who pays the piper calls the
tune and that's the problem
that's the problem with that world order
that there suggests oh wouldn't it be so
nice you can get
global free trade and you know all the
prices of goods goes down and yeah you
might lose your job and yeah we might
not have any manufacturing in the united
states and
yeah as a result of that opioid
overdoses might go up and yeah suicides
might go up
but we'll get really cheap consumer
goods and we'll have relative peace and
won't that be nice
who's calling the shots then that's the
trouble who's calling the shots
some sort of international organizations
international
trade treaties that have no bonds of
loyalty to
our local communities to our families to
our states to our country
no accountability obviously to you the
citizen
that that's the problem you lose all of
the political
rights that we've come to cherish in our
self-government here in the united
states
there is no such thing as a free lunch
he who pays the piper calls the tune and
so
we're beginning to realize that now and
the people who have who have gone all in
and put all their chips in
on this utopian vision of a world order
based on
trade and primarily trade with china are
trying to defend that they're defending
that by
lying to you and they're they're doing
that by defending
one of the worst regimes ever in the
history of the world the chinese
communist party
and they're doing it through absurd
tactics like trying to blame europe for
the virus
or you know just whenever you point out
that china might have a problem they
call it a conspiracy theory and then
when it turns out the conspiracy theory
is true
they call you a racist that's what they
want according to liberalism
all of politics is reduced to economics
okay i mean this of liberalism on the
left what we call progressivism or
leftism
and i also think of that on the right
you know the kind of
more squishy conservative types the the
people who
still view politics primarily
economically and during a pandemic
that's a good time to remember
that we are not primarily economic
actors i mean
just consider just consider the new york
times uh
yesterday two days ago for mother's day
they put out this piece
forget pancakes pay mothers it's an idea
that's gaining currency on the left
and even a little bit on the right this
idea that the state
should pay mothers to raise their own
children one lesson from the pandemic
child care is work and it should be
compensated
after just six days of sheltering in
place i found myself thinking about all
the women i'd taken for granted
so this woman kim brooks writes i
started with griselda who cared for my
kids when they were babies a few hours
each week
if someone had asked me why i paid these
women to do things that i could do
myself particularly when i made so
little money
with the time they freed up i'd say that
i did it
because i wanted to work because i
needed to work not just out of economic
necessity
but also out of a need to feel like a
full human being how sad is that
apathetic
that in this liberal order we're told
that the only thing that matters
is is your job your core your making
widgets
as a middle manager at widget inc is so
much more important
than raising children even though the
hand that rocks the cradle rules the
world
that that's that's a a novel concept and
obviously this woman has bought it
hook line and sinker throughout my
thirties i found myself
largely occupied with keeping a home and
raising children this work despite
bringing joy and meaning to my life
shared many of the qualities
of the menial jobs i've done before
but there was one small difference the
work i've done as a mother i've done for
free
so she says it brought it's like the
compliment sandwich you know it's
brought a lot of joy and meaning to my
life but actually it's terrible and i
hate it
and you know look we i've i've gotten
paid for other work i want to get paid
for this work
you didn't do it for free you got
children
you got a family out of it that's the
pay
that's a good thing that's a lot better
than making 15 bucks an hour at the
widget factory
then she points out that she had a she's
been divorced
with attitudes like this okay you know
maybe not the most shocking thing to
learn
i mentioned this article because some
conservatives are are
embracing these kinds of ideas they say
oh maybe it's a good idea
if if the problem is that all people are
now being compelled to go
work at the widget factory they're all
being compelled just to get jobs and not
raise kids
maybe we need a new government policy a
new
uh entitlement or something to encourage
women to raise kids
no you're being played for suckers if
you think that's what this is about and
this woman actually admits it she says
in 2012
the marxist feminist federi silvia
federici
published a collection of essays ms
federici writes to say that we want
wages for housework is the first step
toward refusing to do it it makes what's
invisible visible and that's the poi
that gives away the whole game
it's it's not the first step in
returning to
raise children and keep a home it's the
first step toward
abolishing it all together toward making
this problem
of economic modernity even worse this
idea that we're all just cogs in a
machine
even worse she says as i wrote this my
sweet daughter reminded me it was almost
mother's day you know and she was gonna
make pancakes
and then this woman's unbelievable she
says everybody likes pancakes but
everybody also likes to be compensated
for the contributions they make to the
world
you are compensated you have a family be
happy have some gratitude
you know it is it's such a ridiculous
argument because they say pay women a
wage
andrew yang said this during the
campaign what's the what's the wage
what's it worth
give me a number what what is what is
the hourly wage or the annual salary
that that mothers should be paid or that
wives should be paid for keeping a home
pick a number you can't because any
number you pick
is going to be offensive there's no
there's no you couldn't go to the
feminists and say okay i'll tell you
what you make 30 bucks an hour 30 bucks
an hour is good it's good wage right
they would be so offended you think my
work is only worth 30 bucks an hour
what is a hundred thousand dollars a
year it's a 24 7 job
right if you look at it primarily as a
job instead of as a life
but there's no price what could the
price be
obviously i'm not going to get paid a
salary to do what i do as a husband
i don't do all that much around the
house as a husband but i guess there's
some things right
maybe emotional support i don't know
what do you how do you quantify
these basic and ineffable aspects of our
humanity
how do you quantify that you can't do it
and yet that's what
these eggheads want to do the egghead
economists on the left and the right
there's an article just came out and
wired
i won't bore you with it it's very very
long and not really worth reading
but it brings up a point that they're
talking about how much is a human life
actually worth
as the us economy reopens amid a deadly
pandemic a dire question
looms let's weigh the risks and do the
math sacrifices have to be worth it the
good has to be greater
how much is a human life worth as a
society we have historically been
willing to incur costs
to save lives and incur and improve
public health care
to save a vast number of lives we'll pay
a huge cost until that cost
seems too high this calculation is
fundamental to the way americans make
policy decisions in normal times
that's not how i view policy decisions
maybe that's how how these modern
utilitarians view it
but that's not how i view policy
decisions and that's not how politics
should be
it's not just a matter of spreadsheets
and tabulating and saying okay this will
save one person and this
the one more person will die one fewer
people will die
no that's not first of all in the
shutdown
there's an irony here because they
locked down to to allegedly save a lot
of lives that's what andy cuomo said and
yet
there's no evidence that the lockdowns
have saved any lives
right the point is don't overwhelm the
health care system and buy time for a
vaccine
none of those happened so no evidence
you saved any lives lots of evidence
that uh the logins have cost lives and
overseas
there's evidence it's going to cost like
millions of lives but even in the united
states
so i don't think you always need to make
that calculation but even if you did
the way to think about politics is not
as just this
cold sterile mathematical calculation
it's about people
and it's about eternal questions what do
we want
what kind of society do we want to live
in one with families or
one with autonomous individuals working
for the widget factory
what kind of how do we best achieve that
how do we view ourselves as just mere
consumers of goods or
as citizens who do we want to rule us
some international trade institution
or we ourselves we the american citizens
what do we want it
ties into open borders right the same
people that are pushing this
liberal global economic utopia are the
ones pushing for open borders because
of course borders wouldn't matter of
course national loyalties wouldn't
matter all that matters
is that we continue to exist as
consumers in this kind of
nation-free world that's one vision and
then there's another vision those are
the questions of politics not just
tabulating things on a spreadsheet
you know but before we go i've got to
i've got to get just a little bit of too
many things to get to
but i've got to get to this transgender
case oh you know i'll tell you a little
bit about it today we'll get into it
more
tomorrow the adf the alliance defending
freedom these guys are so great
they filed a lawsuit against the
connecticut interscholastic athletic
conference on behalf of of three girls
who were they're runners and
they were forced to compete against boys
in girls sports
because the boys identified as girls
this is the problem
when it comes to to sporting of
transgenderism right is that boys
compete against girls and boys are
stronger than girls so boys win
and then therefore there's no more girls
sports so they file this lawsuit
the judge in this case
he decides to hear the case but he says
hey
you can't refer to those boys as boys
you have to refer to the boys who
identify as girls
as girls or as transgender girls or
whatever
but of course that's the problem if you
it's actually about the premises
if you begin the case by saying those
boys are really girls
well then the plaintiffs have already
lost the case right you you're already
saying
i i believe that you are in the wrong
here i'm gonna rewrite
the meaning of sex in title nine
i'm gonna redo that myself as a judge
that's we'll get a little bit more into
that case
tomorrow because it's a very important
story but
this is the way the deck is sort of
stacked against you in the language
this is the way the language matters so
much the chinese virus of the european
virus they're trying to win
at the game of politics before the
debate even begins before the case
is even heard now finally before we go
this story i just couldn't pass this one
up
this from slate which teaches us so much
about our relationships
i love my boyfriend but want a
girlfriend
this is what a woman is writing him into
slate he doesn't want to open up our
relationship
my partner is the most compassionate
loving and respectful partner i could
ask for he has supported me through
difficult times weight fluctuations
questioning my gender changing my name
and sobriety among other things yikes
i'm incredibly attracted to women
oh man this guy so you
question your gender while you're dating
this guy he sticks with you
you change your name he sticks with you
you change your appearance a lot he
sticks with you
you've battled addiction he's stuck he
sticks with you
but now you say i'm incredibly attracted
to women and so you want to sleep with
other people
he knows this we've talked about opening
our relationship however he's on the
spectrum of asexuality
and is only interested in having sex
with me
i don't know you might have missed it in
all the jargon that's just a term for
monogamy
there's the spectrum of asexual
asexuality i guess means you don't want
to have sex
so if you are having sex if you do have
sex sometimes then you're not asexual
you might not be uh a uh nymphomaniac or
something but you're not asexual
but he's only interested in having sex
with me meaning he's
my boyfriend he didn't used to have to
explain what that term meant
the thought of me having sex with other
people makes him deeply uncomfortable as
we both relate to sex in different ways
we have had this conversation a few
times in the year that we've been
together
but with no solid plan or outcome i
respect and appreciate our relationship
more than my desire to sleep around but
i'm worried that i will be missing
something
i'm only 20 and i know that feelings
change but he's an incredible domestic
and sexual partner
yikes man that's like a damning with
faint praise that's what you say about
the love of your life he's a very good
domestic and sexual partner yeah so
and i would like to be with him for a
long time not forever
not endless love but you know for a long
time is there a way to figure this out
or will this core incombatability be
what breaks the support what's the
incompatibility
he wants to date you and you want to
cheat on him that's the incompatibility
i actually sort of feel for this girl
she's obviously very confused and she's
being encouraged in her confusion by a
very confused culture
she said she's young and we're told that
the whole
whole purpose of life is to get as much
pleasure as we can that's the only point
of it
and so if you're young and you're not
sleeping with a ton of people all the
time
then you're you're missing out on life
because we're told that monogamy and
commitment and marriage is bad and we
should delay it and put it off i was
told this for much of my life
certainly by the popular culture but
that's kind of the culture we're living
in
and we're told that you know sleeping
around
and and all that sort of stuff is
really ultimately fulfilling which if
anyone's ever tried it you find out in
the end it's not ultimately all that
fulfilling
is there a way to figure this out yes
here's the way
don't sleep around simple as that
don't view your partner as an instrument
for your own pleasure
view him as a real life human being with
flesh and blood
and a soul that you are not just taking
from
but you are giving yourself to
comes down a lot to these political
questions that we're talking about
all right we're not just we're not just
here
looking at our fellow americans and
seeing them as as
sort of instruments for our own pleasure
and our own benefit
we're not just looking around at our
politics that way either
we are citizens we have first of all
we're members of families and we're
members of communities and we're members
of states and we're citizens of this
country
we have loyalties we have duties we have
affections the media doesn't know that
the media has totally sold out their
country and now they're shilling
for our number one geopolitical
adversary they they have no
understanding of this at all
they're willing to go to the highest
bidder whoever is going to buy them off
like china that's what that's one
version of the world not not all that
different from the way this
this chickie is thinking about life
either but that's the wrong way it
ultimately
will not be particularly gratifying you
will find much more
uh much more satisfaction in
gratitude your your babies are not just
an instrument for your pleasure and you
you shouldn't be paid
to raise your own children right you
will find much more
satisfaction in a position that views
the world with some gratitude
with some humility with some loyalty
and with with you having a a real role
in it rather than this total
alienation willing to be bought off by
the highest
bidder like our sad pathetic
mainstream media apparatus that
president trump very rightly is smacking
down
and we will continue to smack down and
we will continue to tell you the truth
about it because
they won't do it that's our show i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies and directed by
mike joyner executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director
pavel wodowski editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva production
assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. if you
prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there